l'année 2022 sera déterminante pour la
biodiversité les états membres de l'onu
vont tenter de s'entendre sur un
objectif ambitieux protéger 30% des
écosystèmes terrestres marins et d'eau
douce de la planète
rencontre avec un couple de canadiens
qui est au coeur de ces négociations
cruciales pour l'avenir de bien des
espèces incluant la nôtre
oh
[Musique]
memphis which is defined face
il m'a remis de top top priority for
everyone evry
[Musique]
la science est on ne peut plus clair
l'accélération des changements
climatiques et la perte de la
biodiversité sont deux crises
planétaires interreliés aux potentielles
catastrophes
vous parlez avec les scientifiques qui
s'occupe de ça ce qu'on voit dans le
visage celle
on sait qu'on ne répond pas bien à nos
défis
on vit dans des grandes crises et ce
temps de faire des actions positif et
pour faire des actions positif les aires
protégées sont la meilleure solution
pour la nature que la nature peut nous
aider
comme jamais auparavant
l'avenir de l'humanité est entre nos
mains saura-t-on faire la paix avec la
nature
contrairement à la majorité d'entre nous
harvey locke et marie-eve marchand ne
s'étonne pas de croiser des ours
ce qu'ils vivent à baffes en alberta au
coeur du tout premier parc national du
canada créée en 1885 le parc est devenu
une référence dans la mise en place
d'aires protégées
ici dans ce parc
on a développé des idées en communauté
avec lost on si vous voulez les idées
fondamentales
séquanais reprotéger à quoi ça sert et
bin fêtais au coeur du développement de
ses idées pour la planète pour nous ce
non seulement pour le canada
lors de notre passage à bam fall et et
2021 l'ouest canadien vivait un épisode
de chaleur extrême sans précédent
[Musique]
normalement ça devrait être super beau
ici les montagnes de vred 6 l'ex
l'horizon
regarde en arrière de moi ça c'est la
bvk m qui vient des feux de forêts qui
vient d'une température jamais jamais
imaginé même au sein de la colonie
britannique il ya deux trois semaines et
ça c'est des changements actuels qui
nous tombe dessus
durant la période
2010-2019 les émissions mondiales
annuelles moyennes de gaz à effet de
serre étaient à leur plus haut niveau de
l'histoire de l'humanité
si nous n'agissons pas aujourd'hui il
sera trop tard nous ne pourrons plus
limiter le réchauffement de la planète à
1,5 degré celsius
personne ne peut se cacher des problèmes
actuels il n'y a pas de refuge sur la
planète d'une crise planétaire et
malheureusement même ici dans ce parc
national qui est là depuis 140 ans on
n'est pas isolés des problèmes plus
larges
[Musique]
la multiplication des vagues de chaleur
des sécheresses et des inondations
excède déjà les seuils de tolérance des
végétaux et des animaux provoquant la
mortalité massive d'arbres de coraux et
d'autres espèces
[Musique]
trouver des solutions aux grandes crises
environnementales est au coeur des
actions du couple tous deux travaillent
auprès de l'union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature
leur but faire avancer le dossier des
aires protégées à l'échelle planétaire
moi je suis le directeur d'un projet de
la commission des arts protéger mondial
donc le mandat était de chercher un
consensus scientifique mondiale sur
qu'est ce qu'on devrait faire et aussi
d'essayer de le faire adopter par le
système de l'onu
de cette réflexion est né le projet d'un
nouveau cadre mondial pour la
biodiversité
l'objectif est ambitieux protéger au
moins 30% des écosystèmes terrestres
marins et d'eau douce de la planète
d'ici 2030
les et protège est un outil pour
protéger la biodiversité pour
sauvegarder les places naturel pour que
les gens puissent aller se reposer se
restaurer mais de base les aires
protégées sont devenus un outil de
première importance pour stabiliser la
planète
la protection des écosystèmes terrestres
marins et d'eau douce permet de réduire
les effets des changements climatiques
ces milieux naturels agissent comme des
puits de carbone en absorbant les
émissions qui réchauffe la planète
on parle des vélos qui vont remplacer
les autos en vie ok c'est une bonne
chose la met au point de vue
d'importance
l'importance de garder la nature intacte
sa fait au minimum un tiers de la
solution au changement climatique
un vélo qui remplace une auto c'est pas
un même niveau
il est de plus en plus évident que la
dégradation et la destruction des
écosystèmes par l'homme accroissent la
vulnérabilité des populations
environ 3,3 à 3,6 milliards de personnes
vivent dans des contextes très
vulnérables aux changements climatiques
quel est le coût de l'inaction
tout simplement cauchemar de xxème
siècle et c'est ça qu'il maintenant le
jeu actuel du 21e siècle c'est est ce
qu'on va déstabiliser la planète
entièrement qui déclenche un cauchemar
dont on connaît pas la fin
et il y a urgence d'agir la liste rouge
de l'union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature estime que
plus de quarante mille espèces sont
aujourd'hui menacées d'extinction
cela représente 28% des 140 2500 espèces
qui ont été répertoriés jusqu'à
maintenant
certains groupes sont particulièrement
menacées comme les amphibiens
les requins
les coraux
et les mammifères
nous sommes comme un taureau dans un
magasin personnes en a la capacité du
tout brisé mais pas de créer donc on est
en cause des énormes dégâts des énormes
d'amal sans savoir comment faire
fonctionner la planète
de son côté marie ève marchand collabore
depuis des années à de nombreux projets
de protection de la biodiversité
tant sur la scène internationale qu ici
au canada
selon elle des provinces comme la
nouvelle écosse la colombie-britannique
et le québec sont sur la bonne voie en
matière de protection de leur territoire
le québec avancé énormément dans les
derniers 20 ans n'a passé de moins de 3%
à près de 17% qui est la norme
internationale
par contre une province comme l'ontario
fait du sur place tandis que l'alberta
père du terme
si on regarde clic avançait plus celle
qui fait le plus de débats et qui se
posent le plus de questions c'est québec
sans aucune question au canada
malgré tout le canada fait aussi bonne
figure dans son ensemble il a rejoint la
coalition de la haute ambition pour la
nature et les peuples ce regroupement de
78 états soutient l'adoption de la cible
qui vise à protéger 30% des terres et
30% des mers de la planète d'ici 2030
cette coalition est coprésidée par la
france et le costa rica
dans ce petit pays d'amérique centrale
d'à peine 51 mille kilomètres carrés on
trouve 6 % de la biodiversité mondiale
[Musique]
mou
c'est aujourd'hui un modèle sur la
planète le costa rica maintenant a déjà
près de 30% de la protéger
après avoir misé sur les industries
forestières et minières il a décidé
d'investir dans sa nature
y ont attiré les grandes compagnies
internationales des multinationales et
les autres qui sont venus investir car
leurs employés veulent travailler dans
un espace un qui va être là pour le
futur
[Musique]
reste que maintenant le défi c'est de
passer de la parole aux actes
sous la direction d'hervé loc le groupe
de travail de la commission mondiale sur
les aires protégées à développer un plan
d'action
il se divise en trois grands secteurs
d'intervention avec des objectifs de
protection qui leur sont propres les
milieux urbains périurbains et agricoles
les terres partagé où l'on trouve par
exemple des milieux naturels et des
activités industrielles
et enfin les grandes zones de nature
sauvage comme le nord du canada
on doit garder sa intactes pour le
climat et pour la nature et pour la
stabilité du système planétaire
[Musique]
la perte d'écosystèmes et de leurs
services à des impacts en cascade et à
long terme sur les populations du monde
entier
en particulier sur les peuples
autochtones et les communautés locales
qui dépendent directement des
écosystèmes pour répondre à leurs
besoins fondamentaux
[Musique]
dans la dernière décennie que ce soit au
canada que ce soit en colombie
britannique où au québec la majorité des
aires protégées de la conservation que
c'est fait c'est avec les autochtones
d'enfants sont et nous tendre la main
c'est à nous d'accepter de changer et de
protéger avec eux
en observant les rocheuses ce jour là on
voit bien que le danger est réel et que
l'erreur serait de se croire à l'abri
même la cible de conservation de 30%
d'ici 2030 n'est qu'une première étape
et qu'est ce que la science dit
actuellement c'est super clair que si on
veut protéger la biodiversité
le fonctionnement de la nature
le climat qu'on devrait protéger au-delà
de 50% de la planète terre et mer
50 pour ça
c'est un pas de géant mais cet objectif
ambitieux est incontournable
c'est un passé l'action et on sait que
les maires solution qu'on peut avoir
pour vraiment changer rapidement la
courbe ou ce qu'on est ici les aires
protégées laissé de l'espace à la nature
pour que la nature puisse nous aider
si on a la volonté sociale et si on
s'appuie on peut faire n'importe quoi
comme être humain
[Musique]
et
c'est établi nous pouvons réduire de
moitié les émissions d'ici à 2030 mais
il faut agir aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et